what's going on guys this is rob and i
want to put this idea out there i don't
know if anything will ever come of it
but i want to put this out there
jensen ackles playing soldier boy from
the boys and in supernatural and
smallville and just one of the coolest
guys ever from the interviews i've seen
this guy should be brought into the
marvel cinematic universe
and he should play hyperion in secret
wars with the russo brothers
and here's the reason why but before we
get into that we got to pay the bills
here on geek culture explained so this
video is brought to you by atlas vpn so
right now atlas vpn has this deal going
on where you can get their service for
like a dollar 83 a month like
that's a ridiculously good deal and for
those of you all who are not familiar
with vpns this is called a virtual
private network what this means is that
when you don't have a virtual private
network and you get on your computer and
you browse the internet your actual ip
address from your house can be seen with
a virtual private network what you do is
you make it look like you're actually
somewhere else now i use atlas vpn for a
couple different reasons the first one
is because of something called
geo-restricting those you guys who don't
know what that means when it comes to
different streaming services out there
oftentimes what they do is they restrict
content based on your geographic
location now in the states it's not
necessarily an issue and so far as like
what you can see in california you can
see in texas but say for example that
you were taking a trip to spain and you
wanted to stay caught up on your shows
you might not be able to see those shows
because you're in spain whereas if you
have a vpn you can basically get around
that another reason why i use atlas vpn
and in this day and age i feel like this
is an incredibly important thing is
because of their data breaching monitor
feature basically meaning that what the
software does is it continually scans
the internet to see whether or not your
personal information has basically been
the subject or been a victim of a giant
data breach that exists out there which
seems to happen more and more frequently
but based on those two things alone i
found atlas vpn to be more than worth
the dollar 83 a month so make sure you
guys check out the link down in the
description make sure you grab your copy
of atlas vpn and let's get back into the
video
so here's the thing when it comes to
jensen ackles being hyperion in the mcu
this really comes from a couple
different places the first one is that
it comes from secret wars which we know
is a project that the russo brothers are
working on we don't know the full scope
of it which is to say exactly how the
movie is going to look or movies if i'm
a betting man i'd say it'll probably be
a couple films i don't know if they'll
do three but i could see them doing two
which honestly after the success of
infinity war avengers in game i think
will kind of be the unofficial indicator
from the mcu that like this is an
infinity war slash avengers in-game
level event that's happening in the
marvel cinematic universe right it's
kind of saying it's two parts which is
basically their way of telling us it's
going to be pretty massive in scope but
the other reason why i think this would
work anyway is because of thor one of
the things to know is that in the marvel
cinematic universe and i'm sure you guys
have felt it by now the concept of thor
is kind of wearing out its welcome to a
degree not in the sense that i that i
don't want to see thor anymore but the
reality here is that when it comes to a
thor-esque character in the marvel
cinematic universe all we have is thor
now that looks like it may change with
hercules because of the post-credits
scene and thor love and thunder but i'm
not entirely sure what they're going to
do with that if taika watiti is going to
be the one to helm that project because
the reality here and you guys may not
know this from if you haven't read the
comics but the way that thor's been
depicted in thor 3 and thor 4 that's
actually how hercules has been depicted
in the comics in more recent years now
whether or not that's going to roll over
into the mcu in terms of personal
mannerisms how the character is written
i'm not entirely sure maybe hercules
will bring us back to what thor used to
be in terms of being a far more serious
character not entirely sure but the
thing about this is that thor in the mcu
is like the only real heavy hitter of
his kind that we have and so far is like
a god that exists out there and a person
who can fly and that kind of a thing now
you can't really fault the mcu for that
because they've been building all of
this up for the last 10 years so with
phase four we're just now getting to a
point where we're after the events of
infinity war and in-game and we can
start focusing on building other
characters some of which or one of which
could potentially even replace thor so
can't really fault him on that too much
but for the nature of hyperion again
kind of looking at the comics here for a
second the nature of hyperion is that if
we go with marcus milton from earth13034
he is by all standards of measurement
the closest you get to a superman analog
that's also comparable to thor and the
reason for this is because the way his
character was done during jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers
which i think we can all agree in more
recent years the marvel cinematic
universe has been heavily basing a lot
of their content off of that in that
story marcus milton was initially
introduced as basically the survivor of
one of the incursions now we already
know incursions exist in the mcu we know
that from doctor strange too and i'll
make a video at a later date that
explores more of what the incursions
what could actually be going on there
but the way this played out is that with
those two universes crashing into each
other that marcus milton actually held
them apart momentarily for a brief
moment right for a few seconds he
basically held two universes apart which
was a testament to how strong he was
ultimately those two universes crashed
into each other but because of the level
of power that hyperion had he actually
survived in what was basically this
empty white space of where these two
universes used to exist in the
multiverse ultimately he's plucked out
of that space by advanced idea mechanics
and then ultimately saved by the
avengers but the way that he was done is
that he was a very boy scout type
character right in the sense that he
always believed in doing the right thing
and so on and so forth when you get to
hickman's avengers and new avengers and
you do the eight-month time skip you
pick up with hyperion eight months later
and he's a lot more battle-hardened and
he's far more in line with like the
nature of thor right like they both
drink mead they both love to fight he's
very much a thor s character and
honestly i think that given the nature
of jensen ackles and the way that he
looked at soldier boy and uh in in the
boys
i think he would be an amazing fit here
but i think he would be a phenomenal fit
here and here's the reason why one he's
already got the voice right there's a
kind of of rough and and grusk voice
that uh that jensen ackles have i i use
gruss because i can't really think of
like a better word right you know what i
mean like just this kind of you know
just i'm jensen hackles yeah i'm a
soldier boy and i'm gonna mess stuff up
you know like that kind of a thing you
know just just that rough that rough
voice you almost almost like a whiskey
voice to a degree but the way he looks
when he soldier boy is very similar to
the way that hyperion looked in the
comics right in the sense that minus the
ponytail right he's just got that rough
and tumble look that hyperion had later
on in the comics and so just based on
that i think it would fit well i think
hyperion would be a great introduction
into the mcu as a potential replacement
for thor or at the very least somebody
to accompany thor to kind of add into it
because i think that that for the most
part a thor type character just kind of
needs to exist if for no other reason
than the fact that we as the audience
are just sort of used to it and there's
success there you can't look at the
first 10 years of the mcu and argue that
thor is not successful he is you could
probably make an argument about thor 4
but i digress the point being that
having a thor type character in the mcu
i think is somewhat of a necessity and i
think jensen ackle's playing the role of
hyperion as essentially a replacement
for thor is a great way to do that
because then it also brings in his own
storytelling one of the big questions
that you would have to ask here though
when it comes to having hyperion in the
mcu is one what would be the scope of
his character in the sense of what role
would he play would the mcu seriously
consider replacing thor with hyperion or
is that spot already reserved for
hercules and the second question you
would have to ask is how are they going
to make his powers work because with the
the nature of hyperion in the in in
marvel comics right that version of
hyperion there's been a whole bunch
there's like king hyperion who basically
killed all the cosmic entities and the
superheroes in his own universe he was
ridiculously powerful and the only
reason he was stopped was because of
adam beshear the blue marvel who is also
just ridiculously broken but the version
that we're talking about here uh marcus
milton from earth13034 he's basically
superman right he's got x-ray vision
telescopic vision the only the only real
power of superman
that he doesn't have as far as i'm aware
is frost breath and even then like i'm a
little murky on that maybe he can do
that i don't really know but barring
that like you read his stories even his
origin is identical to that of
superman's and so that that really goes
into like how powerful he is that he had
to be a character that was comparable to
superman both in terms of his origin as
you know in his looks as well as his
level of power i mean hyperion is is
crazy overpowered in the comics and so i
imagine the mcu bringing him in would
probably scale his powers down to
something comparable to thor now one of
the funny things is that with the nature
of thor in the mcu he's not that far off
from the comics in terms of his strength
and durability and what he's capable of
the only thing that we haven't really
seen in the mcu that thor has in terms
of power is the god blast we haven't
necessarily seen that as far as i'm
aware maybe we have right maybe it's
just one of those things that they just
kind of gave to us didn't really draw a
whole lot of attention to and wildly
scaled it down but the god blast of thor
in the comics was enough to like
overpower a celestial so it's a pretty
huge amount of energy that he has he
doesn't use it very often i also don't
think that we've seen thor's berserker
rage in the mcu but maybe maybe i missed
that thor does have a berserker state
that he goes into it's called the
warriors madness but i don't think we've
seen that in the mcu but i digress here
the point is that thor's pretty accurate
in the marvel cinematic universe
compared to his comic book version minus
one or two differences it's like a
totally different game with the
incredible hulk but when it comes to
hyperion is that something that would
continue would they keep his power
comparable to what it is in the comics
or would they decrease his power that's
one of the big questions to ask going
forward from phase really phases one two
and three into phase four going forward
is the marvel cinematic universe gonna
start offering this drastic scope of
power i mean the scarlet witch is a
great example of a character who seemed
to largely be innocuous in terms of
their powers getting a massive power
boost now how far reaching that goes i
don't entirely know but the point is
here that we could be looking at a
position in the marvel cinematic
universe going forward where they start
rolling in these major heavy hitters and
they don't decrease their power right
they don't knock them down from as
powerful as they are in the comics or if
they do it's a name it's a decrease in
maybe marginal waste depending on the
type of movie that they're making but
regardless let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section right
let me know if you guys feel like seeing
hyperion in the mcu played by jensen
ackles is a legitimate possibility
because i feel like he looks the part
and also make sure you guys check out
the link in the description to get your
copy of atlas vpn thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace